going to speak to journalists you know
shop of Oliver in Moscow now I
understand that it's a Russian President
Vladimir Putin has been talking about
this what's he been saying
that's right Mr Putin said moscow's air
defense worked properly but the
authorities do know what to do in order
to continue strengthening its defenses
Ukraine is provoking Russia according to
the president therefore Russia will have
to think how to react in the future well
for those not directly affected by the
Drone attacks life still goes on and
people in the streets do not seem to be
very much concerned about the the attack
so all the airports in the capital the
Moscow Metro as well as the rest of the
public transport are working as usual
here there were also some official
reactions according to Andre Carter Polo
the head of the stadium committee on
defense the UAV attacks on Moscow and
the region had goal had a goal to spread
panic among the population and he
explained the the fact Act of the UAV
flying over Moscow and and his luxurious
suburbs by saying that Russia was a very
large country and there was always a
loophole where drone could uh could fly
and bypass the areas with air defense
systems by the way one of Vladimir
Putin's residences is also located not
far away from those affected areas also
according to kreblin's spokesperson
Dimitri peskov the morning attacks in
Moscow were the retaliatory measures by
Kiev they were carried out in response
to Russia's Sunday's attack on one of
decision centers in Ukraine and he added
that the special military operation will
continue
Julia ever since the the war in Ukraine
began the Russian media and the Kremlin
have been managing very carefully the
the way that it is portrayed to to the
Russian people when Russian people see
these drone attacks in the center of
Moscow does that change the way this
receive what's happening
uh the Russian people believe that
President Putin and the authorities have
Unleashed that military operation to
protect them and to protect Russia the
military operation was explained here as
a necessity to protect uh the
russian-speaking citizens of the donbass
on the one hand and uh to protect Russia
on the other so since February 2022
Russia's special miniature operation has
been carried out on Ukrainian soil not
here in Russia and many Russians have
been watching the conflict on television
and now we're all able to watch it
basically from the window and see how
the conflict is uh splashing out onto
the Russian territory you know shop of
Oliver in Moscow thank you very much
indeed